[Musique]
il est là
le silence
les silences et l'espace des recherches
de l'essentiel les silences et qu'on va
un rendez-vous avec soi
si nous fermons les yeux et nous suivons
notre intelligence à cette réalité
invisible
nous serons la constatation sensorielle
et la prophétique comme partie de nous
est né et mis en orbite pour l'infini
faisons l'expérience
fermez les yeux pendant cette seconde
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
bonjour à tous
je vous parle de silence parce qu'il est
silence c'est essentiel d'un autre vie
car nous sommes les interprète de notre
partition personnelle secondaire les
silences il est essentiel la partition
toujours il est là
de nouveau j'ai vu vous raconter une
histoire liée
l'harmonie la mélodie et l'improvisation
cette histoire je la connais très bien
car c'est la mienne et même temps
c'est aussi la vôtre
comme disait les théologiens Lisieux
nous savons tous absolument tous les
mêmes exigences inscrits d'un autre cœur
nous savons besoin de vérité des
justices des beautés d'amour et des sens
positifs traçant dans notre vie
mon histoire commence en 1968 au Mexique
je suis le dernier d'une famille des 10
enfants né d'une mère mexicaine d'une
paire autrichien
si vous saviez
les histoires que j'ai vécues
délirantes rocambolesque et improbable
mais allons directement jusqu'à 2010 que
ma famille et moi sommes arrivés en
France
à Kos peut-être grâce à la crise
économique en Espagne dans ma recherche
de travail en France je suis passé par
un cabinet de recrutement la personne
qui m'interviewait
dans la certification bio et dont les
paysagisme
je comprends pas votre CV
vous êtes atypique et polyvalent
j'étais perdu
mais j'ai de trouver ma capacité des
récits
d'adaptabilité et des créativités pour
mes réinventer et pour travailler en
France sans parler français et son
samedi plan brique connu par l'état
français mais avec l'expérience d'avoir
travaillé dans plusieurs entreprises
dans trois pays différents
les travail et l'expression des lettres
j'avais besoin de m'exprimer
donc j'ai écrit avec d'autres personnes
une société et plusieurs associations
quelques années plus tard en étant les
principaux fondateurs de la Chambre
Économique de Mexique en France j'ai
commencé au même temps à donner des
cours dans différentes disciplines dans
cinq écoles de commerce j'ai donné mes
cours principalement en anglais
et finalement en septembre 2021 j'ai
intégré à plein temps comme responsable
pédagogique on est grande et historique
école des commerces à Orléans
j'aime apprendre à apprendre
j'ai enseigné avec une pédagogie
innovante significative
je suis également monsieur c'est pour ça
que je vous parle d'un parallèle entre
les éléments constitutifs et les
compétences psychosociales ou en anglais
sauf qu'ils pour moi les premières
éléments de l'hémicycles c'est le
silence
il est là
je pense aux méthodes des coachings
comme possédait sacronymes Go réalise
objectif and weh qui demande toujours au
coach de laisser la place au silence
pour aider la personne à écouter et
comprendre ses propres pensées
nos pensées
nos rêves nos désirs sont la chose la
plus réelle de notre existence
rythmée par la réalité ils sont les noms
de notre partition personnelle
les rides
battements de notre cœur
qui comme les rythmes silencieux du
printemps il arrive
il est toujours là dans notre cœur
comme notre rythme cardiaque
comme notre respiration
comme la planète qui tourne autour de
soleil des cycles et des répétitions
infinitum qui continueront même que nous
serons
capotes
mais avant d'équité ces mondes nous
pouvons découvrir les rythmes de notre
vie comment on regardant arrière dans
cette expérience passée qui ne sont fait
réfléchir à prendre et grandir comme je
les lycéens
et qui faisait une bêtise audition jouer
au fausses notes
qui est en train de grandir
les rythmes de notre vie peut-être non
stop
et la seule chose qui nous libère des
séries de maternelle
c'est un moment des détentes des
silences pour briser le Sark les vicieux
psychosomatiques avec un nouvel et 12
cadence
souvenez-vous de cette saison des
rendez-vous avec soi
maintenant maintenant imaginez-vous
dans votre espace préféré dans votre
lieu magique
et pensez à l'éternité cette seconde
l'harmonie
nous savons tous
écouter de la musique et de la musique
il est en principe réacteur qui est la
note là à 440
c'est la référence pour accorder les
instruments et les fashion analogues
pour accorder notre vie les diapason
c'est la réalité on a l'équation avec
les exigences des notre cœur
dans son livre l'erreur des Descartes il
démontre à travers des sa recherche que
les cœurs et les cerveaux sont en
quelque sorte les mêmes choses
mais la différence stade
ce n'est pas cogito ergo Soum je pense
donc j'existe mais plutôt
scintillant
je sens donc j'existe
car nous sentons les choses avant de
réfléchir sur elle
les émotions sur la condition de la
rationalité et je suis sûr que vous
savez sûrement le constater que les
grandes solutions pour les solutions les
gains résolutions de notre vie vient
très souvent de notre cœur
et pour notre harmonie personnelle c'est
si important
l'acceptation de notre héritage
génétique et culturel et l'adéquation
de nos valeurs et nous croyons ce qui
créent les comportements que nous savons
récemment
je suis allé au Mexique
car ma mère qui a 97 ans s'est cassé les
codes de mur
en lui donnant la main
je prenais conscience à nouveau
de la valeur des gestes et des mots
quand j'ai fait en 2018 quand mon frère
a décédé d'un cancer foudroyant je l'ai
accompagné la dernière semaine de sa vie
que reste-t-il de tout ça
pour moi
c'est l'apprentissage profond
que chaque vie touche beaucoup de vie
il est que la seule façon d'aimer surrer
notre vie c'est à travers la qualité des
non rencontres
et des partages des moments forts plan
des sens pour établir la quintessence
des relations humaines
les plus importants c'est l'expression
nous mène et pas la perfectionnelle qui
ont donné aussi
qu'il a perfection de l'exécution de
l'exécution vont moins que les
sentiments et la vibration des émotions
la mélodie
nous sommes tous nés avec une mélodie
particulière avec des talons naturels
des capacités et des compétences que
nous pouvons cultiver tout au long de
notre vie mais notre valeur autant que
personne c'est ontologique il n'est pas
déterminé par nos compétences et nos
talons mais qui s'additionnent mais
plutôt par notre attitude qui multiplie
l'ensemble
nous sommes des humains avec des
ressources et non pas des ressources
humaines
mon talon bizarre
c'est de jouer avec mes mains faire de
la musique avec mes mains comme je le
fais quand j'ai vécu assez joué de
flamenco avec nos amis
mais comment on découvre notre mélodie
particulière notre
singularité il faut d'abord
identifier à travers nos expériences
vécues
et nous réalisation provente pour les
cultiver et l'utiliser pour minimiser
nos serrures récurrentes
pour trouver l'équilibre
dans sa océan de sa constance
volatile un certain complexe et un vieux
sachant qu'il est pire tempête crée les
meilleurs capitaines et que nous tous
nous tous ici présent on s'est rejoint
d'un autre
j'ai compris aussi la sagesse des mots
du poète andalou Antonio
il n'y a pas de schéma les schémas s'est
fait en marchant
arrière on va les schémas qui ne sera
plus jamais traversé
j'ai compris aussi qu'il n'y a pas de
dichotomie entre les savoir-faire et les
savoir-être mais il faut plutôt savoir
être pour savoir faire
l'improvisation
mais comment nous pouvons s'apprendre
les savoir-être c'est simple on existant
face à la réalité avec notre besoin de
nous adapter
et l'adaptabilité c'est des compétences
plus importantes car elle nous permet de
nous réinventer à chaque instant et
chaque instant c'est un nouveau
commencement
j'aime la musique
j'aime improvisé et de voir m'adapter au
rythme des autres émotions
j'aime spécialement la musique de jazz
car il permet de
compenser en temps réel avec un liberté
total
je pense que dans la vie
nous avons s'agir
comme nous c'est vite à faire la chanson
d'éduquer
et
swing doit
et dormir
mais maintenant
pour
finaliser comme nous savons tous de la
nostalgie pour les futurs
je vous invite à mettre toutes les
musiques et à redécouvrir la musicalité
de votre vie
d'abord
trouver votre moment des silence
préférée votre unique
après
penser à votre rythme intérieur
votre
pulsation interne pour calibrer votre
métronome émotionnel avec vous même
développer votre mélodie unique soyez
vraiment vous-même non
et surtout
cultiver votre capacité d'improvisations
pour avancer dans la vie comme si la vie
était un conserve jazz
[Musique]